well i'm still nursing a hangover from
that very memorable wedding feast but
nothing will stop me from taking a look
at next week's preview breakdown which
sees a ton of new characters and the
series largest time jump to date this is
a spoiler-filled video so if you don't
want to know what's going on leave the
video on mute so i can still get that
sweet sweet watch time as always i've
left a link to the trailer in the
description but please come back i am
very lonely we open on daemon
targaryen's dragon karaxis this looks to
be somewhere along the narrow sea
perhaps closer to dragonstone or
driftmark as we'll see the prince very
close with lena valerian the two shared
a flirty dance last episode but 10 years
have since passed and a lot has changed
daemon is now married to lena lena was
betrothed to a sea lord of braavos and
in the book damon actually ends up
killing this man in a duel and taking
lena as his wife but considering the
time jump this is an event we'll likely
not see in the show let's go over this
new makeup of the small council at the
head of course we have the king who has
managed to defy death but not losing his
hair this dude really has seen better
days and i pray for alice since he
stopped those late night booty calls the
king's hand is still sir lionel strong
and both rhaenyra and alicent have spots
at the table something that's not in the
book they even have their own marble
balls rhaenyra's black and allison's
green we'll see those two colors come up
a lot we have a new grand maester or
wild who we saw briefly last episode and
has taken over grand maester melos job
after his passing it's difficult to make
out but it seems thailand lannister is
still master of ships and lyman
beesberry master of coin but who is this
to the right of rhaenyra if we go by the
book and use process of elimination it
would have to be sir jasper wilde the
new master of laws however we do know
the show can vary wildly from the book
daemon has apparently left the
stepstones undefended it's still a
volatile region with triarchy forces
often attempting to take back land
claimed by daemon during the war for the
stepstones alicent and rhaenyra also
still seem to hate each other's guts you
can see her wearing green here which
lara said is the hightower color for
going to war i wonder if alisent has
confronted reneira about her hookup with
sir kristen or if she's let that fester
for all these years in voice over we
hear lara strong proclaim what are
children but a weakness as we get our
first look at eamonn targaryen alice and
viserys's third child now i made this
family tree before the season started
and now that we're getting to see more
of these characters i'll start to update
some of these photos so bear with me
eamon stumbles upon a dragon who may be
either dream fire or vermithor perhaps
we're somewhere in the depths of the
dragonpit as aymond will have grown up
in king's landing in one of the other
trailers we see aemond on a beach
claiming vegar but it's unclear whether
that will be in this episode or down the
line currently vegar is ridden by lena
however during the birth of her third
child who comes out twisted and
malformed and dies within the hour she
contracts a fever and dies in the first
trailer we see a funeral at driftmark i
wonder if this is for either elena or
lenore notably absent in this trailer is
lenore in the book he's murdered in
spice town so it'll be interesting if
the show starts with him already dead or
if we'll see this play out damon and
laina have twin daughters baila and
reina one of whom we see here in the
courtyard at teenage aegon ii viserys
and allison's eldest son knocks down one
of ranira's kids a likely jacaris her
eldest just like alison and ranira hate
each other so do their children hate
each other it leads to a bitter rivalry
which the king just laughs off notice
how even the children wear green and
black tunics overseeing this sparring
match is sir harwin strong who is
believed to be the real father of
rhaenyra's three children this is due in
large part to rainier's kids not having
the trademark silver hair there are some
other features but i won't go into too
much detail harwin's gotta know this kid
is his but he can't really step in and
do anything about it which is an
interesting dynamic and what the heck is
this weird chair the king is in notice
he's not standing perhaps his illness is
making it difficult for him to stand for
long periods of time here's a heated egg
i wonder if this is in preparation for
lena's child remember in episode 2 that
demon stole an egg from the dragon pit
to put in the crib for messaria's
non-existent child we'll later see
either bayla or reyna hold an egg near
the fire this is a much better shot of
aegon ii with allison's voiceover saying
that he will be king at this time
rhaenyra is still set to be heir but it
looks as though the queen has committed
to doing whatever it takes to get renera
off that throne a quick shot of lena and
damon will later see the two riding
their dragons side by side and just take
a look how absolutely massive veigar is
here currently the oldest and largest
living dragon i've heard some people say
this dragon is sun fire but the fact we
later see him being commanded by jacaris
leads me to believe it's a vermax who
he'll eventually ride here's jacarys and
rhaenyra holding a baby in the book
there's only a three year age difference
between rhaenyra's eldest and youngest
from her first marriage it's my guess
that this baby is her third child
joffrey named after lainer insisted the
child be named after his former lover
joffrey lonmouth here we see a concerned
lionel and some intrigue around a father
being concerned about the acts of the
sun considering we see harwan here it's
implied that this is referring to
rhaenyra's children being his and here's
old viserys sitting down once again
giving me the same look my grandpa did
when i tried to explain what twerking
was here we have harwin going to town on
sir kristen cole with aegon eamon
jacarys and lucerus watching in the
background with harwin firmly on team
rhaenyra and kristen team allison
something has obviously pissed harwen
off maybe kristen made a snide comment
about rhaenyra or harwin being the
father of her children in the book there
is mention of a brawl occurring after
eamonn calls rhaenyra's sons strongs the
result of this brawl is harwin being
removed as princess rhaenyra's champion
by king viserys maybe this scene is some
sort of adaptation of that and kristen
would obviously be protecting eamonn and
here's viserys in front of that damned
model city as alison tells her husband
to have three children look nothing like
their father it's an insult it seems the
main drive of this episode will be
centered around this rumor that rhaenyra
has been sleeping around with harwin and
that her children are his there are
three random shots that don't give away
too much like renera holding joffrey
alison having a drink after a long day
of trying to destroy her former bestie
and loris who you gotta keep your eyes
on he's always up to no good here's a
shot of someone who kinda looks like
lionel but this dude's got some hair up
top it's not looking good for him and on
the top right we see some guards
approaching looks like this guy might be
getting something chopped off and in
game of thrones that's never a good
thing here we see the aftermath of some
sort of fire or explosion there's a dead
body being carried on a stretcher and
behind them someone with a bucket of
water rushing past for those of you who
have read the book there is one
particularly famous fire that occurs at
harrenhal in which both lionel strong
and harwin are burned alive perhaps this
is that event and there is a brief image
from one of the previous trailers that
shows someone possibly harwin burning in
this fire jacaris takes after his mother
saying the word dracharus ordering his
dragon to roast some goat there seems to
be no shortage of fire this episode and
a lot to look forward to including our
first taste of olivia cook and emma
darcy as alison and raniera if you want
more game of thrones content be sure to
check out my full episode breakdowns
i'll leave links to those in the
description thanks for watching be sure
to like and subscribe and for more bad
takes you can follow me on twitter and
instagram at think story yt until next
time remember so far i'm giving dolores
four peter baelish's out of five